Hagamos otro problema de razones que ya es
prácticamente un clásico.
Supongamos que inicialmente tengo cierta cantidad
de fruta, así es que tengo cierta cantidad
de fruta...
regresaré a eso en un momento...
pero sabemos que la razón... la razón de manzanas...
y voy a poner manzanas en rojo...
la razón de manzanas a naranjas,
naranjas lo pongo en anaranjado...
se parecen un poco estos colores...
Sabemos que la razón
de manzanas a naranjas es de 5 a 8...
es de 5 a 8...
también se escribe como 5 a 8, así tal cual,
esa es la razón de manzanas a naranjas.
Ahora, lo que también sé de este problema
es que cuando elimino 15 manzanas...
así es que elimino...
elimino 15 manzanas...
15 manzanas...
y la razón...
la razón resulta 1 a 4...
la razón de manzanas a naranjas resulta en 1 a 4...
¿Cuántas manzanas... cuántas...
no mejor... cuántas en total... cuántas...
déjame escribirlo así mejor...
cuántas frutas en total tengo...
tengo después de eliminar...
después de eliminar las 15 manzanas?
Así es que después de eliminar las 15 manzanas,
¿cuántas frutas en total me quedan?
Hagamos un poco de álgebra,
digamos que "x"...
digamos que "x" es el número de frutas...
el número de frutas...
al inicio...
el número de frutas que teníamos inicialmente,
¿cuánta fruta nos va a quedar al final?
Si quitamos 15 manzanas, no estamos haciendo
nada a las naranjas "x" menos 30...
lo voy a hacer en un color distinto...
"x" menos 30...
no... "x" menos 15...
"x" menos 15,
esto va a ser el número de fruta que tenemos al final...
el número de frutas que tenemos al final,
sabemos que estas dos se cumplen,
sabemos también que la razón de manzanas a naranjas
con la que empezamos es de 5 a 8...
la razón inicial de manzanas a naranjas
es de 5 a 8.
¿Y esto que quiere decir?
Bueno, quiere decir que si nosotros hacemos
grupos con nuestra fruta,
siempre vamos a tener una relación
de 5 manzanas a 8 naranjas,
o si ponemos números precisos,
si tomamos grupos de 13 frutas por cada grupo...
por cada grupo de 13 frutas...
por cada grupo de 13 frutas, vamos a tener,
hay 5 manzanas...
hay 5 manzanas y 8 naranjas,
por cada grupo de 13 frutas
¿y cuántos grupos de 13 frutas hay?
Bien, si "x" es el número total de frutas,
entonces si dividimos "x" entre 13,
si dividimos el número total de frutas entre 13,
éste de aquí es el 13, éste es el 13,
entonces si estoy dividiendo
el número total de frutas entre 13,
lo que estoy obteniendo
con esta cantidad de "x" entre 13,
el número de grupos de 13 frutas
que inicialmente puedo formar.
Ahora, por cada grupo, tengo 5 manzanas,
¿cuántas manzanas tengo inicialmente?
Si este es el número de grupos que tengo
e inicialmente tenía 5 manzanas por cada grupo,
inicialmente tengo 5 por "x"
sobre 13 manzanas,
ahora, por cada uno de estos grupos
también tengo 8 naranjas,
¿cuántas
naranjas tengo?
Tengo 8 veces eso,
por cada grupo de 13 tengo 8 naranjas,
así es que tengo 8 por "x"
sobre 13 naranjas.
Bien, eso es lo que tenía al inicio,
al eliminar 15 manzanas,
la razón de manzanas a naranjas...
la razón de manzanas a naranjas resulta ser 1 a 4,
es igual a 1 a 4,
lo cual quiere decir que por cada grupo...
por cada grupo de 5 sumamos estas dos cantidades,
1 y 4 = 5, por cada grupo de 5 frutas hay...
por cada grupo de 5 frutas hay una manzana...
1 manzana y 4 naranjas...
y 4 naranjas...
Muy bien, entonces,
¿cuántos grupos de 5 frutas tenemos?
Bien, esta es la cantidad de fruta que nos
queda ya que quitamos 15 manzanas,
así es que
¿cuántos grupos de 5 tenemos?
Tomamos la cantidad de fruta que nos queda,
"x" menos 15 y la dividimos entre 5
que es el tamaño de cada grupo,
así es que esto nos va a dar, esto es igual al número de
grupos de 5 frutas...
grupos de 5 frutas.
Ahora, en cada uno de estos grupos voy a tener
1 manzana y 4 naranjas, así es que
¿cuántas manzanas y cuántas naranjas me quedan una
vez que he quitado 15 manzanas?
Pensemos,
¿cuántas manzanas voy a tener?
Tengo 1 manzana en cada uno de estos grupos,
así es que el número de grupos es el número
de manzanas, así es que son "x" menos 15
sobre 5 manzanas,
¿y cuántas naranjas voy a tener?
En cada uno de estos grupos
voy a tener 4 naranjas,
así es que multiplicando 4 por el número de grupos lo cual puedo escribir como 4/5 por "x" menos 15,
esto nos va a dar el número de naranjas...
naranjas... de acuerdo,
4 veces el número de grupos de 5 frutas.
Bien,
¿qué es lo que no cambia?
Alteré el número de manzanas pero no afecté
el número de naranjas, así es que este número,
el número de naranjas que tenemos al inicio
es igual a este número,
el número de naranjas
que tenemos al final.
Hay muchas maneras
de atacar este problema,
pero ésta fue la la que se me ocurrió
como la más directa.
Encontremos entonces el valor de "x",
estas dos cantidades tienen que ser iguales,
nunca cambian, esto lo podemos escribir matemáticamente como "8x" sobre 13 es igual a 4/5...
4/5 que multiplica a "x" menos 15 y aquí
quizá lo mejor que podemos hacer es
multiplicar todo por 5/4, multiplicamos
entonces por 5/4 el lado izquierdo
y multiplicamos por 5/4 el lado derecho.
Estos términos se cancelan el coeficiente
se hace uno y del lado izquierdo que obtenemos,
4 entre 4 es 1, 8 entre 4 es 2,
así que nos queda 5 por 2 = 10,
"x" sobre 13, "10x" sobre 13,
que es igual a "x" menos 15.
Ahora restamos "x"
a ambos lados de la ecuación,
así es que la ecuación resulta
"10x" sobre 13 menos "x", es igual a -15...
vamos a bajarnos un poco...
vamos a hacer la resta de
"10x" sobre 13 menos "x",
reescribimos el lado izquierdo como
"10x" sobre 13 menos "13x" sobre 13,
lo cual es igual a -15,
"10x" sobre 13 menos "13x" sobre 13
es igual a "-3x" sobre 13,
lo cual sigue siendo igual a -15.
Y ahora, multiplicamos por -13/3,
multiplicamos por -13/3 del lado izquierdo
y multiplicamos por -13/3 del lado derecho.
Y multipliqué por -13/3
para cancelar los 13 y los 3 aquí,
estos signos menos se hacen más y nos
queda del lado izquierdo tan solo "x",
¿y del lado derecho qué nos queda?
Este menos y este menos se hacen más,
este 15 y este 3 se pueden dividir entre 3,
15 entre 3 es 5, 3 entre 3 es igual a 1
y me queda tan solo 5 por 13,
este más de aquí era para indicar que se transformaban en positivo el producto de dos signos negativos,
¿así es que 5 por 13 cuánto es?
5 por 12 es 60, 5 por 13 es 65,
pero esa no es la solución,
recordemos que establecimos que "x"
es el número de frutas al inicio
que acabamos de calcular es igual a 65.
Pero la pregunta que nos hicieron,
la pregunta que nos hacen es,
¿cuánta fruta tengo después de eliminar 15 manzanas?
Así es que nos piden el valor de "x" menos 15,
después de que eliminamos 15 manzanas,
la cantidad de fruta que nos queda es "x" menos 15,
65 menos 15 son 50, nos quedan 50...
50 manzanas, no, no son 50 manzanas,
más bien son 50 piezas de fruta.
Nos quedan 50 piezas de fruta,
eso es lo que nos preguntan.
Si quieres puedes checar
cuantas manzanas tenía al inicio,
cuantas después que eliminé 15,
cuantas naranjas había y todo lo demás,
pero lo que nos están preguntando es
¿cuántas frutas en total tengo después
de eliminar las 15 manzanas?